[Música]
este sábado el ministro de defensa de
Rusia sergeygu visitó las tropas rusas
en el frente estuvo en zonas devastadas
y entregó medallas a los soldados la
inteligencia británica confirmó que el
ejército ucraniano enfrenta la presión
de las fuerzas rusas en batmut ciudad
que el grupo Wagner dice tener
prácticamente rodeada
el presidente francés está en la
República democrática del Congo la
última parada de su gira para renovar
las relaciones con el continente
africano en King shasa macron anunció
una iniciativa de ayuda por 34 millones
de euros para el este del país y aseguró
que todos los actores del conflicto
armado están de acuerdo en un alto el
fuego
en Irán un centenar de niñas han sido
hospitalizadas por envenenamiento con
gas en seis centros educativos del país
Teherán informó de la creación de un
comité para investigar los ataques que
se repiten desde hace semanas voces de
la República islámica señalan a grupos
fundamentalistas que se oponen a la
educación de las niñas
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles empezamos con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania porque
este sábado el ministro de defensa de
Rusia sergeygu visitó a las tropas rusas
que combaten en Ucrania se trata de una
de las raras ocasiones en las que un
alto comandante ruso ha visitado el
frente desde que Putin lanzó su llamada
operación militar especial hace más de
un año a través de Telegram el
Ministerio de defensa de Moscú publicó
imágenes de shogu condecorando a los
combatientes rusos visitando zonas
devastadas del donbas e inspeccionando
un puesto de Mando en el sur de donaska
y una de las batallas más largas de la
guerra en Ucrania podría entrar en sus
últimas horas las fuerzas rusas afirman
tener a bacmut prácticamente rodeada una
situación confirmada este sábado por la
inteligencia británica este viernes el
grupo Wagner pidió a las tropas de kiev
que abandonen la zona para evitar más
pérdidas humanas y este sábado el jefe
del grupo de mercenarios rusos publicó
unas imágenes con lo que serían los
ataúdes de soldados ucranianos en el
vídeo el fundador del grupo paramilitar
dice estamos mandando otro cargamento de
soldados ucranianos a su casa veamos el
informe sobre la situación en el terreno
esta carretera es una de las únicas vías
de entrada y salida de bahamut la zona
ha sido testigo de los combates más
feroces de la guerra hasta ahora las
fuerzas rusas dicen que tienen la ciudad
casi completamente rodeada y es solo
cuestión de tiempo hasta que la tomen el
viernes el jefe de Wagner joylene pidió
al presidente ucraniano bolodimir
selenski que ordenará La retirada de
bajo mud para salvar la vida de sus
soldados pero según dichas tropas no
tienen planes de Rendirse
las fuerzas rusas están intentando rogar
al ejército ucraniano que abandone para
que dejemos de defender la ciudad
esperan hacerse con la ciudad sin
grandes pérdidas pero han perdido a
tanta gente que la catástrofe para el
grupo Wagner y el ejército ruso es
inevitablemente el viernes la agencia de
noticias Estatal rusa riano bosti
publicó estas imágenes muestran un
puente en las afueras de bahamut
reducido a escombros en el vídeo pueden
verse tropas pertenecientes al grupo
Mercenario Wagner afirman que fueron las
fuerzas ucranianas las que destruyeron
el puente intentando detener El Avance
ruso los que aún viven en la ciudad y
sus alrededores están sometidos a un
bombardeo casi constante solo quedan
unos 5.000 de los 70.000 que vivían
antes de la guerra y para los que quedan
es una lucha diaria
hay problemas con la comida solo nos dan
alimentos humanitarios una vez al mes no
hay electricidad ni agua ni gas tomar
bahamut sería una victoria altamente
simbólica para Rusia
Moscú considera la ciudad como un
trampolín para tomar ciudades más
grandes como kramators y es Love yours
más al oeste
y el apoyo diplomático aquí eff continúa
expresándose en forma de visitas de
altos cargos occidentales a Ucrania este
viernes el fiscal general de Estados
Unidos Mary Garland visitó el VIP
invitado por el Ministerio Público
ucraniano Garland abordó la necesidad de
recoger evidencias de los presuntos
crímenes de guerra perpetrados por las
tropas rusas durante la invasión para
hacer rendir cuentas a Moscú el mismo
propósito abordó este sábado la
presidenta del parlamento europeo
Roberta metzola que junto con la primera
dama ucraniana olenas de lenscap
protagonizó un panel donde denunciaron
la violencia sexual ejercida por
soldados rusos contra población civil
medzola se reunió también con follodi
mix de lensky Y ambos mandatarios
expresaron sus deseos de que el proceso
de adhesión de Ucrania al bloque
comunitario empiece este año
cuando decimos que Ucrania es Europa y
Europa es Ucrania eso significa que las
negociaciones de adhesión Deben comenzar
lo antes posible y con suerte para este
año estamos impresionados con el
progreso que los ucranianos han logrado
con las recomendaciones de la comisión
europea yo creo y el parlamento cree que
tenemos que igualar ese Progreso con
eficiencia y rapidez de nuestro lado
Cómo avanzamos en los titulares un
centenar de niñas fueron hospitalizadas
este sábado en Irán al ser envenenadas
con gas en al menos seis centros
educativos femeninos repartidos por todo
el territorio iraní Este es el más
reciente episodio de unos ataques que se
producen desde hace semanas en decenas
de escuelas de Irán y que las
autoridades detenerán han prometido
investigar mediante un comité especial
algunas voces de la República islámica
apuntan a grupos fundamentalistas que se
oponen a que las niñas reciban educación
en las escuelas según medios estatales
citados por la agencia reuters a raíz de
los hechos algunos padres habrían sacado
a sus hijas del sistema educativo
y en la capital china en Beijing empezó
este sábado una de las citas clave del
partido comunista chino se trata de la
conferencia política consultiva número
14 del comité Nacional del pueblo chino
un evento que funciona como el antesala
del Congreso popular nacional que se
celebrará el domingo la doble cita pone
en marcha el plan trazado durante el
vigésimo Congreso Nacional del partido
comunista el año pasado cuando se aprobó
el inédito tercer mandato de schimping
como secretario general de la formación
y que con toda probabilidad supondrá
ahora su continuidad como presidente del
país entre los asuntos nacionales en la
agenda el escenario postpandemia después
de abandonar la política cero covid
también la situación económica el
desarrollo militar o el conflicto entre
Rusia y Ucrania
en otras noticias en Turquía una de las
principales políticas de la oposición
turca Indicó que su partido rompe con
una importante Alianza formada para
desafiar al actual presidente allí
erdogan en las elecciones previstas para
mayo
meraltecer líder del partido
nacionalista allí dijo que se estaba
distanciando del grupo de seis partidos
conocido como la mesa de los seis por
una disputa sobre la Selección del
candidato que se enfrentará erdogan
dos meses antes de que Turquía acuda a
las urnas los opositores al presidente
receptam han recibido un duro golpe el
viernes una de las principales políticas
de la oposición del país Indicó que su
partido se está distanciando de una
importante Alianza formada para desafiar
a erdogan
a estas alturas el partido bueno se ha
visto obligado a una imposición obligado
a elegir entre la muerte y la malaria
tal y como se ha hecho a la nación turca
durante años y por supuesto nos
doblegaremos ante esto
la decisión llegó cuando la fundadora y
jefa del llamado partido del bien mral
acenner anunció que no apoyaría a quemar
oglu líder del principal partido de la
oposición en su lugar ha apoyado a otros
dos candidatos
mansurgás alcalde de ankara y ekrem y
mamoglu alcalde de Estambul
hemos expresado nuestra opinión sobre la
candidatura de dos personas cuyos
nombres hemos oído con frecuencia en las
calles tiendas y plazas públicas durante
más de tres años son los favoritos y a
quienes hemos visto ganar al Señor
erdogan en todas las encuestas públicas
imamoglu es una figura popular y ha
obtenido buenos resultados en las
encuestas sin embargo actualmente está
apelando una decisión judicial en su
contra que de confirmarse le impediría
ejercer la política juntas supondría un
gran impulso para el presidente actual
cuya popularidad se ha visto gravemente
afectada por la debilidad de la economía
y la respuesta de su gobierno al
mortífero terremoto del mes pasado
cambiamos de información el presidente
francés Emanuel macron se encuentra en
República democrática del Congo la
última parada de su gira por el
continente africano que también lo llevó
a gabón Angola y Congo en King shaza
decenas de manifestantes recibieron al
mandatario francés por un lado con
rechazo a la influencia francesa en la
región y por otro lado con exigencias
para que París apoye sanciones contra
Ruanda estado al que la República
democrática del Congo acusa de estar
vinculado con Los Rebeldes de la
guerrilla m-23 de hecho macron anunció
ayudas económicas a la ciudad de goma al
este del país en la zona afectada por el
conflicto
por ello Francia será el primer estado
en responder a la iniciativa de la Unión
Europea anunciada esta misma mañana de
Establecer un servicio aéreo humanitario
a goma liberaremos una aportación
inmediata de 34 millones de euros en
ayuda humanitaria que se sumarán a la
cantidad de casi 50 millones anunciada
por la Unión Europea
vamos ahora con noticias de América
Latina porque en Colombia este viernes
fueron liberados 79 policías y seis
trabajadores que habían sido retenidos
el jueves durante una protesta campesina
en San Vicente de caguán en el
departamento del caquetá al sur del país
los hechos se produjeron en medio de
protestas contra la petrolera emerald
Energy a la que reclaman por presuntos
daños ambientales y destrucción de vías
en la zona el presidente Gustavo Petro
anunció que se reunirá personalmente con
los locales
las acciones violentas y las vías de
hecho sólo generan más violencia y no
facilitan los espacios de diálogo entre
las partes para encontrar acuerdos un
grupo de funcionarios de la regional
caquetá se encuentra en la zona para
verificar de primera mano la atención
médica de los heridos abrir mesas de
diálogo y Buscar que terminen las
acciones violentas para establecer el
control y la tranquilidad de la región
por otro lado la oficina de Naciones
Unidas para los Derechos Humanos
presentó un informe en el que muestra
que en Colombia diferentes tipos de
violencia como las masacres o los
asesinatos a líderes sociales aumentaron
en 2022 Manuela Cano tiene los detalles
la violencia en Colombia no cesa la
oficina de Naciones Unidas para los
Derechos Humanos reiteró su llamado para
acelerar el desmantelamiento de los
grupos armados del país el pedido se
enmarca en un informe que presenta
cifras desalentadoras sobre la violencia
en Colombia el año pasado hemos visto el
efecto de la violencia de los grupos
armados en los territorios y por eso
llamamos tanto a la política de
desmantelamiento porque son los grupos
armados no estatales y las
organizaciones criminales quienes están
generando tanta violencia en los
territorios las masacres en el país
aumentaron a 92 en 2022 En comparación
con las 78 2021 también en el año
anterior 116 líderes comunitarios y
activistas sociales fueron asesinados
con respecto a los 100 que murieron en
2021 hemos visto que en el 2022 siguen
habiendo altos niveles de masacres
homicidios de personas defensoras además
de la violencia cotidiana que sufren las
poblaciones y la la construcción del
tejido social en los territorios
2022 fue un año de transición en
Colombia la presidencia pasó de manos de
Iván Duque de tendencia derechista a las
de Gustavo Petro el primer mandatario de
izquierda del país un cambio en el poder
que también se reflejó en la concepción
de cómo contrarrestar la violencia Petro
ha impulsado como base de su programa
político la paz Total que busca abarcar
a los diferentes grupos armados del país
el gobierno ha reiniciado conversaciones
con el ejército de liberación nacional y
ha acordado el cese al fuego con bandas
criminales y dos facciones de las
disidencias de las FARC unos pasos que
siguen estando lejos de su meta de
ponerle Punto Final al conflicto de más
de 60 años en el que al menos 450.000
personas han perdido la vida
la fiscal general de Ecuador Diana
Salazar solicitó este viernes el arresto
domiciliario para el expresidente Lenin
Moreno por un caso de corrupción la
decisión se da en el marco del caso sino
hidro que gira en torno a presuntos
sobornos recibidos por la construcción
de la central hidroeléctrica coca codo
sinclar la fiscal consideró necesaria la
prisión preventiva para los 37 imputados
en el caso pero la Constitución de
Ecuador impide esa medida para los
mayores de 65 años como es el caso de
Lenin Moreno este domingo la justicia
decidirá Cuántos sospechosos Irán
finalmente a prisión preventiva
digamos así al final de esta edición
informativa pero sigan con nosotros
enseguida volvemos
[Música]